Scott Lang, you're reality. Everything you're holding on to.
I know how it ends.
You're out of your league. Ant-Man.
Scott, I need you to be the Ant-Man
You have a chance, the chance to earn that
look in your daughter's eyes
to become the hero that she already thinks
you are
Second Chances don't come around all that
much
second chances don't come around all that much
is this an old message? it's the front gate.
time works differently in the quantum realm
what if we could enter at a
certain point in time, but exit at another point in time
we could bring everyone back
my whole life happened because I messed up
not everybody gets a chance to save the world
Avengers Assemble
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
Marvel dropped a new Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania trailer so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos there's
a whole bunch of stuff coming up there's more
trailers I think coming next week and the
week after that Marvel just had their big
Brazil Comic-Con CC XP panel that's why it
feels like trailer Fest this week with a bunch
of Marvel Star Wars Disney related trailers
I will do videos for some of the other stuff
that dropped recently as well too but the
big thing in this trailer is they just hype
up more of the interaction between Kang the
Conqueror and Ant-Man I love the way that
he checks Ant-Man during their conversation
there where he's like you're out of your depth
you're out of your league Ant-Man there's
a bunch of extra footage that they put in
the d23 trailer that they didn't release online
that isn't in this or the previous online
trailer where basically Ant-Man shows up and
tells him I'm an Avenger like you should be
afraid because I just defeated Thanos with
the rest of the Avengers in endgame and this
is basically King telling him that that means
nothing to him Thanos was nothing to him because
you remember a little while ago we saw the
Loki season 1 episodes I did a bunch of videos
for it so I'll link those Below in the description
and the Loki season 2 trailer because we'll
see another version of Kang but during that
we saw the TVA which is sort of like their
version of Kang's chronopolis from the comics
or immortus's chronopolis which is like the
last version of Kang from the end of his timeline
he who remains and in that they showed you
how he had rendered all the different Infinity
Stones from different timelines completely
inert like they were no threat to him at all
during all of Paul Rudd's interviews during
this Comic-Con event he was wearing one of
the infinity gauntlets the Stark Tech Infinity
Gauntlet yeah that's that's beautiful that's
amazing amazing really which is a good point
of reference because he just got done doing
that in in the trailer they have this funny
joke at the beginning where they confuse him
for Spider-Man because Spider-Man is way more
famous but the whole idea is that after Avengers
end game he's become way more famous like
he's riding very high he benefited greatly
from the fame that the Avengers got for saving
the world he's written a book look out for
the little guy things are going well with
his relationship with hope Van Dyne with his
daughter Cassie Lang who he's been reunited
with the much older version of Cassie Lang
who has been recasted this is Catherine Newton
playing the character the reason why the actress
changed is because the original actress during
Avengers endgame was cast by the russos and
she decided to go to college so he thinks
she was unavailable also Kathryn Newton is
a much bigger star so there might have been
just some behind the scenes stuff where they're
like you know what if you're going to go to
college go to college we'll just find a bigger
actress to play the character it's not quite
the same thing with the Don Cheadle recasting
of roadie war machine there wasn't any big
drama or anything like that behind the scenes
typically with the younger actors like the
child actor with the kids if they want to
go to college they usually just take a couple
years off from acting and then come back to
it so they could always say that she's just
a variant of Cassie Lang like this was happening
in another reality so the idea is that when
Ant-Man and the rest of them are sucked down
into the quantum Realm by Kang trapped by
Kane Cassie is captured by him and Ant-Man
is forced to help him complete his device
to leave the quantum realm so that he could
win the Kang Multiverse war and bring about
the events of Avengers 5K Dynasty like we
know that move is going to happen so we know
that he has to escape the quantum realm initially
when he's faced with this he's so overconfident
because of what they did defeating Thanos
in Avengers end game the king completely smacks
him upside the head metaphorically and literally
probably too like please I'm King the Conqueror
I don't care about Infinity Stones also inside
the quantum realm they're protected from things
like snaps because of the way the quantum
realm exists relative to the rest of reality
in the Multiverse the whole thing with the
quantum realm is that it's sort of like the
blood vessels of all of reality all Dimensions
all universes all timelines one single a place
where you can control all of time all of reality
which is why Kang wants it so badly but the
whole idea is that he's been trapped down
there like when he traveled down there something
happened to trap him it seems like his ship
was destroyed or partially destroyed because
if you look at this red energy that Ant-Man
flies to when Kane tells him that he has a
special mission for him like you have to steal
something for me and I'll give you back Cassie
Lang I can give you more time quote unquote
which is a reference to the five years that
he lost with his daughter it seems like something
happened with Kang's first ship because this
just looks like his technology in this red
energy arcing all over the place those broken
pieces it looks like reality is fractured
time has fractured something about this place
has rendered is so dangerous that Kang has
been sending other people to try and get something
that he needs from it these seem like Ant-Man
from different parts of his timeline and you're
gonna see a couple of them die like everybody
makes jokes about Ant-Man dying during this
one because Kang is so swole what's the definition
on this brother all right here we go what's
this
you ain't never seen nothing like that before
and that's down to the intensity and how hard
he trains his work ethic that's enough about
Jay Jonathan Majors worked out hardcore for
this the reality is that they wanted to have
their cake and eat it too which is why you
have variants like the whole concept of variance
you can kill a whole bunch of them and the
real one still winds up making it to the next
movie so both Kang and both our version our
main version of Ant-Man will make it out of
this movie alive but not every single variant
of Ant-Man in the d23 trailer Kang says have
I killed you before when he says that he's
an Avenger meaning that he's already killed
many versions of Ant-Man and many versions
of the Avengers age is a reference to him
being Kang the Conqueror like oh I've been
to many other timelines I've conquered them
many other universes I've conquered them and
I've killed all these other versions of Avengers
it's also a bit of a Sly reference to this
scene too where it seems like he sends Ant-Man
to steal this device from his wrecked ship
and a bunch of them wind up dying if you zoom
in enhance on this scene you can actually
see there are hundreds of variants of Ant-Man
in the background like tons and tons of Ant-Man
so the joke is army of ants it's an army of
ants men the reason why this is the first
official movie in Marvel Phase 5 is because
it's establishing Kang the Conqueror as like
the preeminent threat in the MCU like the
next big threat after Thanos but someone who's
way way worse than Thanos relevant side note
this is also Kang from the comic showing you
how powerful he is using his power over time
to kill Thanos on the spot speeding up thanos's
own personal timeline in the localized area
here so the ages eons in seconds so this movie
is just meant to show you why he's so much
more dangerous than Thanos to the MCU because
it's like the very beginning of Marvel Phase
5 and they want to show you why the Avengers
just can't roll over him right away like why
don't the Avengers just defeat him right now
because he's such a badass one of the other
big things too is that he was stuck in the
quantum realm for 30 plus years since Janet
Van Dyne escaped but time moves a little bit
differently so he's been stuck down there
way longer remember his real name is Nathaniel
Richards he was born in the very very distant
future like thousands of years in the future
he started out as a normal scientist before
he became king the Conqueror and then traveled
into the quantum realm but because the way
time works because of when he came back in
time he met Janet Van Dyne when she was stuck
down there and they worked together because
they're both Geniuses to try and Escape until
Janet Van Dyne found out what he was planning
on doing then left him stranded and was able
to detect Hank pym's signal and Escape before
Kang found them but in the time since that's
happened he's found a way to detect any kind
of signals like that so when he detects Cassie
Lang's signal he just Yoinks them down into
the quantum realm to force them to help him
escape people have said it's weird that Janet
Van Dyne withheld that information but I think
the idea is that she never thought that they
would go back down to the quantum realm so
it would never be a Potential Threat the Hawaii
with Cassie Lang is that she's going to become
a version of stinger during the movie that's
why she's wearing the purple suit from the
comics her powers are very similar to The
wasp's powers that's why her suit is kind
of like the wasp suit she's meant to be a
chip off the old block and one of the jokes
about Ant-Man is that he's a little bit like
Spider-Man and that they both cause a lot
of the own problems that they wind up having
to solve during their Adventures like man
winds up getting himself into a whole bunch
of trouble and that winds up being the plot
of the movie Cassie Lang is doing the same
thing like she's almost too smart for her
own good curiosity killed the cat so to speak
curiosity freed the Kang the Conqueror Jonathan
Majors did say we would see many different
variants of Kang across Marvel Phase 5 and
Marvel face 6 before Avengers 5 King Dynasty
we'll also probably see a bunch of variants
of him during Kang Dynasty as well I know
there's lots of theories about variants of
Kang pretending to be other people like you
have iron lad in the comics who's like a young
version of Kang it is possible that that will
happen in the future MCU Marvel Phase 5 movies
Marvel phase six I think what will happen
is we'll find out later that like a couple
Kang variants have been hiding out in the
MCU by the time we get to King Dynasty like
a lot of them won't be revealed until Kane
Dynasty that movie is meant to be a little
bit closer to the plot of Avengers King War
which is a little bit different like the roster
of New Avengers will be similar to The New
Avengers that we see in the MCU but they're
changing some of the plot to just fit with
what they've already done in the MCU so far
so all the continuity works out and the whole
idea with them doing King Dynasty and Secret
Wars back to back is that they're doing the
same thing that they did with infinity war
and Avengers end game with the big time jump
in the downer ending for Infinity War that's
why I think at the end of Kang Dynasty The
Avengers will be unsuccessful Kang will wind
up winning like Thanos wound up winning and
snapping the infinity gaultle at the end of
infinity War he'll wind up collapsing all
of reality all timelines to one reality like
the battle World reality with one world then
when Secret Wars begins that'll be closer
to the plot of the more recent version of
Secret Wars with some Easter eggs for the
classic 80s Secret Wars also a couple of changes
just to fit with what they're doing in the
MCU because there'll be like a lot of characters
that they won't be able to include in the
movie version then like the comic book version
of Secret Wars at the end of that they'll
fix the Multiverse so to speak with a couple
of changes probably because I think a lot
of the X-Men stuff that Kevin feige is building
up to like the new X-Men movie The Core X-Men
characters will see after Secret Wars in a
lot of what will happen will be the result
of what happens during Secret Wars like oh
all these X-Men are showing up out of nowhere
is because we fixed the Multiverse but we
didn't fix it perfectly like there were a
couple extra changes he did say a Brazil Comic-Con
that will see more mutants during Marvel Phase
5 and Marvel Phase 6 but he dodged the question
on X-Men specifically so he's using the term
mutant differently from X-Men when you're
talking about X-Men usually you're just talking
about the core team like really good example
is Hugh Jackman's Wolverine core X-Men character
but we know he's coming from the Multiverse
so we think the idea is that they're going
to recast a lot of the X-Men characters not
every single one but a lot of them and a lot
of them we won't see till after Secret Wars
but there'll be a couple that we'll see before
that if he's spotted any other Easter eggs
during this that I didn't talk about in the
video just write them Below in the comments
I've done a couple other videos I've talked
about Bill Murray's character so I'll link
that at the end of this I'm working on an
Indiana Jones 5 Dial of Destiny trailer video
there were a couple other trailers like Transformers
rise of the Beast I'll try to do videos for
all that stuff be sure to enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss it and if you
you have any requests just post them in the
comments below everyone click here for my
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer video and
click here for that other Ant-Man 3 Quantumania
trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!